[Music]
all right hi my name is Gerren and I
would like to talk today about what
happened to our JavaScript phones I want
to start off with a hypothesis which is
that nobody in this room actually has a
hacker phone about 5 to 6 years ago
I feel like I could have asked you all
this kind of conference if you had some
kind of experimental device running
Firefox OS or a bun 2 or something
actually like on your person right now
and there would have been a fair amount
of hands in the air given the
demographic of this conference but today
I doubt that there are any of those
devices actually here in the room unless
you brought them here specifically to
troll me am i right I'm assuming that I
am so I think it's fair to say that
hacker phones as a concept just kind of
disappeared we all just sort of gave up
and we went back to our iPhones and our
androids and it wasn't for no reason we
got better cameras faster modems and
greater stability these phones seemed to
get more and more expensive like I can't
even fathom how I would have justified
paying over a grand or nearly a grand
for my first candy Martineau Kia but
they also become more impressive and
they become more able to replace our
real computers so you could say then
they cost more because they helped us
accomplish more and they go far beyond
what we could have done with hacker
phones except they don't work like real
computers we're locked into somebody
else's vision of this sort of like IKEA
office computer that looks pretty
convincing but it's actually quite
limited and you don't if you don't like
the vision that you're offered you have
at maximum one alternative option and so
maybe that's why I'm up here today
wondering what happened to the
JavaScript phones that we're supposed to
like blow up this field and put the
future of these little computers back
into the hands of your average
JavaScript developer
the way we kind of grabbed the web back
from my e5 and flash interestingly what
happened involves a bit of all the
things I just mentioned the stunning
cameras the connection speeds the
stability of the firmware and it might
seem superficially like this is this
triumph of the free market where the
products that one did so because they
were simply better products it's
actually more of a triumph of old boys
networks of monopolies the obtuseness of
infrastructure and go to all the fashion
having lots of lesser capital to throw
at something so that nobody else can
compete on your level it's not a story
of the natural evolution of products to
become better it's the story of
capitalism rewarding capitalism so let's
go back those five or six years to when
some of us thought it might play out
differently there are a few things I
think are relevant to examine from that
time that should have culminated in a
great JavaScript phone the interest in
PhoneGap / Cordova and all the related
toolkits
or tools the exponential adoption of
node and nodebots being like there are
teas and coffee brewing or bread baking
or knitting or whatever it is that y'all
are into these days of the day people
were searching for ways to make use of
their web skills on their phones they're
putting node everywhere they could think
of and everybody seemed to suddenly have
a soldering iron if that's not a recipe
for a JavaScript phone I don't know what
is the some of you were babies and you
won't remember that time so real quick
let's talk about the details first the
state of mobile development was really
unresolved people were already
developing native apps and they were
making quite decent money off them
because there just wasn't as much
competition and so naturally developers
who didn't work in the native languages
of the platforms wanted a piece of that
too or their employers or clients did
and from there we got things like
PhoneGap PhoneGap was eventually bought
by Adobe and became Cordova and if
that's still not ringing a bell it was a
tool to allow JavaScript developers to
write a JavaScript application
compiler to native code there was a lot
of focus on making normal hosted web
apps and websites mobile-friendly their
toolkits such as a mobile version of
jQuery UI and emulators and tons of
theorizing about responsive design that
started appearing out of nowhere to meet
the needs of smartphones you could
compare it to the current consensus that
we should all be producing accessible
websites oh but in this case we actually
went and did something about it at this
point
testing cross browser had been a pretty
significant and limiting piece of work
fairly recently so adding mobile
browsers and generated mobile apps to
the list of things to check felt pretty
natural and everybody wanted to be on
everybody's phone so we all just did it
that's the front end on the back end you
have note which at this point is still
fairly new or at least is still being
treated that way it's gone through a few
years of people insisting it's just
merely a novelty and then people
insisting that it'll never have the
robustness of nginx or the developer
friendliness of Ruby or the corporate
assured reliability of dotnet as far as
I know Express has existed since a few
minutes after node was released and so
people have been using node as a
webserver all this time but even the
node community itself has tried to
distance node from being a web server
and from the more general concept of
server-side JavaScript and what I always
kind of read is an unfortunate giving in
to pressure from hacker news type people
to be more serious and of course there's
nothing more serious than hardware so at
this time if you go to a JavaScript
conference you can pretty much assume
you're gonna see people playing with
little circuit boards with wiki lights
on them and if somebody is no copter is
gonna be sitting on the ground
surrounded by a crowd of people like
dad's at a barbecue around a classic car
up on blocks gathering speculation about
what actually needs to be fixed and how
sweet it's gonna be when it actually
runs but of course the hardware itself
is just marketing for some pretty
interesting new uses for JavaScript
which is now being used to scripting
--zz that have nothing to do with markup
and not even necessary
visual interfaces and why not scripting
languages are lovely to work with if
introducing the additional layer of
abstraction doesn't slow things down
massively javascript has been getting
faster more powerful for years at this
point so the easy of adoption makes it a
very attractive interface to code
against there's one more big thing
that's happening at this point in time
which is that there's a JavaScript phone
and at a conference like this a bunch of
people would have had one we'll talk a
little bit about Firefox OS in just a
second but first you may or may not have
noticed that there's still an elephant
in this room maybe now it's more clear
why it seemed like we could have a
JavaScript phone but what made us think
that we should if you're sitting here
thinking yeah that was a really good
idea why didn't that happen why do you
think that personally I wondered if
today it's too late I don't know if
people still feel this way or if the
ship has sailed
several years ago though it was too
early to wonder that another advantage
for Apple and Google kind of sharing a
smartphone monopoly is that they've had
the privilege of training us all to use
their products if you think back though
people used to have tons of complaints
about the phone interfaces but if your
echo chambers like mine that sort of
grumbling has died down over the recent
years and if anything maybe you're left
with a little sniping back and forth
about whether Android or iOS is better
probably not even that though because we
have no or limited opportunity for
personalization and for deviation from
this sort of single sanction set of use
cases there's nothing on our smart
phones to really get invested in now but
I didn't use to be true there are
probably even now things on your phone
that kind of annoy you but you found
workarounds for them like maybe the mail
client isn't full-featured enough for
the maps give bad directions assistant
preferences seem intentionally hard to
set and confusing I think the big reason
that people wanted a JavaScript phone is
because several years ago most serious
JavaScript developers still had
writing interfaces even if we weren't
designers per se we felt we could do
better because phones in that point were
like this trash heap of badly
functioning operating system and carrier
installed apps and the third-party apps
that might have improved that situation
were treated as super sketchy I believe
people went a JavaScript phones because
they wanted to make the software on
their phones live up to the promise of
the hardware so you've been very patient
waiting for me to say something Firefox
OS and now I'm gonna say something about
Firefox OS Mozilla had a project called
bucho gecko that was meant to give us
all JavaScript phones and people were
really excited about it Mozilla was
probably the only company that could
have pulled this off being a huge
company that nonetheless maintained
pretty open back-and-forth with the web
community as a whole and isn't the same
sort of growth focused business that
Apple and Google are in facts Mozilla
was planning to sell a $25 phone the
plan was to bring the power of
smartphones to everyone by using the
power of web technologies so that's
clearly not happened to understand why
we need to talk a bit about hardware and
what goes on inside these little
machines your phone is a tiny little
computer but it's also kind of not it
contains a lot of the same pieces as the
computers that you work with the
processor modems sound and graphics
cards but they're in a different format
from the early days personal computers
were hobbyists friendly devices it
wasn't at all unusual to like order all
the parts for your computer like via
mail and build it yourself to have your
own machine even big brand desktop
machines as recently as the dawn of
wildly available cell phones where
things you kind of expected to customize
but that's never been the case with
phones handheld devices have always been
largely single units that weren't
intended to be customized let alone
built from spare parts but today you can
still get an Esprit know and a GSM
shield and you can make something
similar to a phone but you'll still be a
very long way off from anything that
would fit the universal definition of
mobile phone
similarly you can sit at your computer
and do pretty much everything your phone
does just using different networks but
we still don't recognize your computer
as a phone the size is a big part of
what makes a phone a phone but the size
is only important because it offers
Portability and portability is only
useful if you can connect to a cell
network this ends up limiting who can
make hardware for phones because the
protocols needed to negotiate a
connection with a cell phone tower are
only licensed to carriers it's not quite
as exclusive as it might sound even the
carriers who have their own
communications infrastructure will
regularly rent space on other networks
for the clients communications but it's
another hurdle for anyone who wants to
start making phones this hardware needs
to be certified by the individual
carriers that it's going to connect to
and then it also needs to be approved by
the relevant governing bodies in
whatever countries it'll be used in for
example the FCC in the United States and
none of the hardware in the phone exists
in isolation so if you love writing
integration tests and stress tests
you'll probably spend a lifetime being
entertained by the process of getting
Hardware certified on the other hand if
you have some sort of different agenda
like actually releasing something just
passing tests and getting certifications
could kind of end up being a lot and
this is where as JavaScript developers
who as likely as not have a front end
web background
we're in unfamiliar territory they may
seem a little hostile because the
regulations around telecommunications
are strict if a connection drops because
of something to do with hardware that
you're trying to distribute you can't
just like throw up an error page with a
cheeky gif and ask people to reload like
who would you even ask the end user the
modem the operating system the phones
tight integration means that if your
hardware [ __ ] up you have to notify
every component involved and if your
hardware is [ __ ] up and making
someone else's component look bad guess
what there goes your certification from
that manufacturer
so say you're building a cell phone and
as an analogy consider on the one hand
writing an application with a bunch of
micro frameworks or on the other using
an all-in-one framework that makes every
decision for you you might be attracted
to using micro frameworks because you
can get the best tool for every job and
nothing you don't need but there's
overhead associated with making all this
sure that all the micro frameworks
cooperate together eventually
especially if every new micro framework
you npm install required you to pay fees
and be recertified by multiple bodies
you might decide to say [ __ ] it and use
the monolith your phone's let's call the
system on a chip with a nice smooth
cover on one side and a big
high-resolution screen on the other
everything it does is part of the same
piece of hardware even the antenna is
cleverly designed to meander through the
phone specific cuts so that it's as long
as possible and takes up all the
available space left by the geography of
the chip there's no market where you can
go and buy the most high-end pieces of
the system on a chip in your phone
the iPhones chip is designed
specifically by Apple and produced
exclusively for them you can't get those
parts a company like fairphone can't get
those parts and Mozilla couldn't get
those parts so when company has produced
a phone they produce the whole thing
start to finish chips to apps so anyone
who wants to come along and make a
JavaScript phone would have to have the
same variety of skills and large piles
of currency that Apple and Google have
at their disposal to make something
comparable to an Android or an iPhone of
course not everyone gives a [ __ ] about
having the highest resolution camera or
even the fastest LTE modem there are
more feature phones available now than
there were a few years ago so I'm using
something like Kos which is based on
Firefox OS sound like the nokia reboots
using old-school hardware manufacturer
operating systems so if lots of people
can come and build a feature phone how
come Mozilla couldn't build a $25 smart
phone with a slightly shitty or camera
the answer which you probably already
knew is that they could have Mozilla
could have bet the whole company on the
high stakes process of becoming a
carrier
so that they could produce their own
hardware and give the world lovely
twenty five dollar JavaScript phones
according to people who worked on the
project they nearly did that anyway
rather than throw everything behind
becoming a carrier they looked for
carrier partners who would certify
Firefox OS like I just said though
becoming a carrier is time consuming and
expensive so those partners wanted
assurance that there'd be lots of
profits in it for them they could load
the phone down with all their carrier
installed apps and they get various
market advantages and like if your this
web standards loving JavaScript pushing
company who just wants to give the world
twenty five dollar phones like that's
not what you're about are there
companies that could probably afford to
be the carrier that Mozilla needed just
as an act of goodwill to the web
community yeah and do the same people
who'd benefit from such a phone give the
same carriers many thousands of dollars
out of a sense to their profession
rehired requires them to own the latest
tech definitely but is there an
incentive for those carriers to back a
competitor who break up their monopolies
no that's business and that's what
happened to your JavaScript phone sorry
to be depressing so now what you're
still sitting here desperately wishing
you had a JavaScript phone there are a
few things you can do which you would
choose depends on what a phone actually
is to you for example most people
probably define a phone is something you
make and receive calls on right but who
in this room uses up all their voice
minutes every month I don't think a lot
of people in the world do so you could
build your own voice an SMS phone with
hobbyist hardware you could wipe the
firmware on your smart phone and put a
more hackable operating system on it you
could work through approved channels and
write JavaScript apps that improve on
the things you don't like or you could
rebel to be honest I avoid working with
hardware because it's a little fiddly
for me but I've spoken to colleagues and
peers about this and it turns out there
are a few din a few little chips you can
use to do traditional phone stuff and
they expose a scriptable inner you can
control with JavaScript and I work for a
company called next mode that provides
an API to do exactly this kind of
communications development so I feel
pretty confident it's possible
you could also just put together a piece
of hardware that works like a MiFi and
use an API like next most to do your
telephony via voice over IP not worrying
about carriers and cell phone towers and
all of that and in theory you can keep
going you get a nice screen and a
graphics chip a speaker and a mic a
powerful antenna and you'd probably end
up with a pretty large thing not one
that matches the power quality or size
of commercial smart phones but you could
you could tick all the boxes then you'd
only have to write the firmware for that
so that it functioned together
seamlessly and automatically and you
didn't have to like start an app and
click a button to connect to the nearest
cell phone tower when every 20 feet by
the year twenty one fifty for your
great-grandchildren might be able to
finish the work that you'd started and
have a working 2019 or a smart phone so
is that the real way forward maybe there
are projects like the light phone that
make for an interesting argument that
the ability to have appealing Hardware
once you scale back functionality is a
good trade-off so maybe a
community-driven JavaScript phone starts
somewhere simple like that rather than
try and compete with smart phones out of
the gate and it builds on the hardware
and firmware iteratively developers of
the whole don't have a great reputation
for patience humility and teamwork so
maybe we better not hold our breath for
a community-led evolution of tell
telephony hobbyist chips you might not
have a lot of friends running custom
firmware on their commercial smartphone
hardware these days but the project's
still exist if you have various
different versions of Android you can
replace the operating system with
something you like better this is
another option I can't speak to you from
personal experience like many people I
experimented with Linux in college and
it's interesting it's a hellscape of
finding drivers for the perfectly nice
hardware I already owned and what are my
operating system to use then is the same
one I'd find myself in if I installed
some version of Linux on my perfectly
nice modern Android and basically gave
up on using the camera or maps ever
again the risk and flashing your phone
is at the very nice hardware that lets
the manufacturer maintain their
is operated by an equally nice
proprietary driver any operating system
under the Sun could just use those
drivers it would end up a pretty [ __ ]
monopoly the things in your phone that
have access to the system typically get
signed by code that lives in a special
secure area of the phone which is its
own processor and memory sealed off from
the rest of the phone if you wipe your
phone you lose access to that area which
you could see as a helpful way of
stopping narrow do wells from taking
over your phone and making it take
pictures of you mining their bitcoins or
a cynical way of protecting intellectual
property probably it's both whether good
bad or neutral though this security is
going to [ __ ] up your phone if you flash
it and a lot of people learn that the
hard way a few years ago and that's
probably why people don't do it as much
anymore there are probably plenty of
people in this room who I've barely
addressed at all that being those of you
who actually write apps intended to be
used on smartphones to be clear there's
obviously nothing wrong with that does
it accomplish the goal of providing
nicer alternatives to the apps the phone
comes with it absolutely does you can
make those apps you can't make those
apps automatic and in some cases you'll
have to convince people not only to like
install your mail client but then to
move the non-removable default to a back
screen somewhere so they don't
accidentally click on it but if you can
write compelling enough software then it
works if you want JavaScript can
functionality on your phone the least
risky most effective route by far is to
write apps it doesn't look much like the
revolution we were promised though does
it
there's one final thing I want to say
and for that I have to ask you to even
further indulge my nostalgia and
selective memory as we go back 15 to 20
years this was around the time of the
web standards movement which you may
remember as a lot of arguing about CSS
versus tables or something to do with
XHTML really though if you were doing
much web development around that time
and though it was a period where
developers like us argued over and over
for taking the more difficult more
expensive and less reliable path of
throwing out perfectly good existing
products to sign on to still very
theoretical open standards
and turn our backs on the powerful
established proprietary languages like
ActionScript that worked great everyday
folks using the web we're not clamoring
for us to break all their [ __ ] web
pages that which came from developers
like us I kind of think the most much of
the evidence suggests that will never
happen that assembler rebellion is
coming from mobile phones and I don't
know exactly what that would look like
or if it has anything to do with
JavaScript but I think it has something
to do with the fatigue that's expressed
by people intentionally trading in their
smartphones for future phones if the
world is deciding that maybe they don't
literally need a thousand dollar
smartphone in their pocket just to take
pictures and send the occasional text
maybe a truly open alternative has a
chance to compete if people switch those
future phones and they don't use as much
data and they have to do all their
texting be a t9 so they don't do that as
much either maybe they don't want to pay
for a blow to package contracts with
carriers and so the carrier's power
comes under threat and maybe then the
hardware but Napoles fragment as
companies have to find a way to serve a
wider variety of interests I mean it's a
lot of maybes but even the tools that
are closed and locked in now sort of
began with people working together on
protocols electronics and computer
science in public
if you lock people into a monoculture
where the most exciting innovation you
can offer them is removing their
headphone jacks
I think they'll eventually start
innovating in other directions to find a
way out of it and I think a JavaScript
phone might still be out there
Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]